[Music]
hello everyone we're gonna go ahead and
get started thank you for coming today
my name is Dave stanky and I'm a
developer advocate here at Google cloud
and we're here today to talk about build
and test when we say build we really
mean build and test because if we didn't
test our code or if we didn't have tests
we can't say really with confidence that
we built it correctly so when we talk
about this today and in general we use
the word build as a shortcut for build
and test and sometimes we use the word
test as a shortcut because it includes
the build process and I'm gonna use that
shortcut today as we go through this
importantly I want you to know that
everything that we talked about here
applies equally to building and testing
so what is this building test thing well
that's the process where we take our
source code we run it through a series
of steps might do some static analyses
or linting then we're gonna do
transpilation or compilation packaging
and turn it into something that people
can run and use as software and the
process by doing that is called a build
process and if you write software or if
people in your organization right
software chances are you have a build
process and chances are you use a build
system to perform that build process and
this can vary depend on the language
that you're working in you probably are
using it everyday or people in your
organization are but you may not think
about it very much but you're probably
using it so do we have any Java
developers in the house all right you
may be using some like maven or Gradle
any C++ developers whew all right common
is make may be in conjunction with C
make I need JavaScript developers all
right familiar with web pack or gulp
these are all different build systems
and there's many many more so the
headline for today is that you have a
choice to build systems and the choice
you make can actually have an important
impact on the success of your build you
might be able to get faster builds and
tests possibly much faster
basil is Google's build and test system
an open source available for free and
it's designed from the ground up to be
fast we can use GCP as an uplevel for
basil to get even faster build and tests
reliably and consistently all right
let's dig in a little on this build and
test thing why do we build and test well
build is into requirement our software
won't work until we turn it into
something that can run test is a choice
but it's a choice that we're all making
right well let's talk about that there
is a wide body of research talking about
how testing is really good testing makes
your code better which makes your users
happy which makes your organization
happy which makes us successful as
individuals and when we add automation
we can do testing at scale we can grow
our code base grow our organization and
keep our software running successfully
correctly so look at the slide it's all
green
there's whoops meant to get into laser
here the green laser it's all green
there's no red there's no pro/con we're
all doing it right we've totally bought
into testing and this is like you know
our bones at this point right or is it
we did a study at Google across hundreds
of organizations and what we found is
that test practice are falling far short
of what our ambitions are very few
organizations build every time they make
a code change and even fewer have
comprehensive test coverage by which we
mean we have tests that cover every code
path in our application it's really
common for a team to only run their
complete test suite once a day maybe
less and that complete test suite is not
all that complete so why aren't we
testing do we really like getting woken
up at 3 a.m. in the morning no I don't
think that's it we know the benefits and
we have the best of intentions and then
reality hits the more tests we add the
more we realize they take
time and resources to run these tests
and it becomes a drag on developer
productivity it's very common to kick
off a build and then head out to lunch
right and then you come back and okay
builds not done let's go get some coffee
alright came back alright still going
I'm at 67% all right gets its beer
o'clock all right here we go
eventually though you want to actually
get back to writing code so what do we
do we take shortcuts we turned down our
test coverage we run them less often and
then that leads to bit rot where don't
even write the test why I ride him if
you're not going to run them and this is
why we're not testing at the level that
we feel we should be we end up in this
conundrum here as you step up your test
practice who's your code gets better and
better but your tests take longer to run
and you need more and more hardware and
that's a tough choice you know what's
the sweet spot in here we can test more
and more and take longer to get our code
out to production or we can test less
and get it out there sooner it's we can
ship it now or we can ship it right I
don't know how to make that choice and
other people struggle with the - in our
study we found that the number one
concern among teams with sophisticated
test practice is balancing test
frequency with the resources required to
run those tests so what if we could
flatten that curve get to a place where
we can have more and more tests and run
them more and more frequently without
incurring increasing an overhead that's
spirals out of control
well hello basil basil is Google's build
system it's been used by nearly every
one of Google's thousands of engineer
tens of thousands of engineers for over
10 years and is available as free
open-source software at Google we have
an intense commitment to testing we
exercise and validate every code path on
every code change and most teams
maintain a very high level of code
coverage and we grew we ended up running
as all of us do into this problem the
conundrum of tech more testing meant
more
we didn't want to slow down and ship
software less often we didn't want to
ship more bugs so we created Basel 2
which needed we created Basel to allow
us to test all the things without losing
that velocity to do so Basel is designed
with two major optimizations that allows
us to run our build and test more
efficiently so the first is don't repeat
yourself if you've already run something
and it hasn't changed why run it again
by reusing the prior results it means
that we can scale our build and test as
our builds and tests scale exponentially
our time doesn't have to scale that way
because we're only going to retest and
Rijeka size the parts that have changed
the second major optimization is to
build and work in parallel so build
actions and especially tests are
generally very parallelizable you might
build one binary and run a whole bunch
of independent tests on it and so by
having this fan-out ability we can run
across modern multi-core systems and get
maximal efficiency what can you build
with with Basel well just about
everything basel provides an extensive
bility mechanism where you use a simple
Python like language to write plug-ins
we call them build rules for various
language this is just a partial list of
the set of languages that have been
built by our community to extend basel
now i've shown this slide many times and
i was at a conference recently showing
it off and someone came up to me and
said alright you got a lot of stuff in
there but what about Oh camel when I
said I don't know I don't know when I
went to my phone and googled it and
found it all right Oh camel we we have
that
so there's Oh camel we actually play a
game at conferences sometimes called you
know stump the basil see if you can come
up with a language that we don't have
build support for and if you do it's
pretty easy to write so you can write
you can use basil across your entire
organization for every language that
you're working in today and tomorrow
let's take a look at how basil works so
first consider a traditional approach
we're gonna try and build this codebase
this is a portion of the tensorflow
codebase it's actually much much more
than that and our goal is to get to an
executive Bowl something that we can run
so the traditional build process works
something like this first we take all
the things and then we do this thing and
that thing the other thing and then we
cross our fingers and hopefully we get
something out that can run now there's
two problems that's what I just
described one is all the things maybe we
don't need all those things for this
particular thing that we're creating and
two is I said this and then that and
then the other this sounds very serial
and I think we know that modern software
is all about parallel so with this we
took a different approach the first
thing we noticed is that source code is
not a bunch of random stuff okay mine
sometimes is but eventually I figure it
out and what I do is I write source code
that is an interrelated set of highly
structured symbols so with basil using a
declarative configuration language we
define the units of code and how they
interoperate basil interprets that to
create actions and each action has fully
specified inputs and outputs these add
up to a unique signature for that action
each of these fully specified signal a
specified actions is independent and can
be individually addressed we know
everything that goes into it and
everything that we expect to come out of
it
we composite these into a graph where
the output of one action can become an
input into the next and these actions
can be cached if the inputs to an action
don't change then we don't need to
regenerate the output all right let's
zoom out this is a graph of a Basil's
build graph a directed acyclic graph of
all of the steps and the flow to get
from your inputs to your route but this
represents a very small one so let's say
we're gonna make a change make a change
to this file and that file
well everything upstream of that is
going to need to be rebuilt so we'll
invalidate the cache for all of these
bits there's a fair amount to do here
but notice there's a whole lot that we
don't have to do and because of Basil's
build graph we know for sure that we
don't have to do it and we're going
get the right output another thing we
can see is that this area of the graph
and this area have no common edges and
that means we can execute them in
parallel now we're ready to build we
rock the graph and arrive at our output
so putting it all together
when I say basal let's build and test
this basal is going to pull in the
inputs generate that that build graph
then consult the cache to see if there's
anything we can reuse prune out
everything that's already been built and
then distribute that work across all the
cores on my machine for parallel
execution and rapid delivery alright
let's take a look let's see unlock my
laptop here so we're going to build an
application so it's a modest java
application for image recognition using
the tensorflow library so it bundles
tensorflow c++ native library to do the
work there we are
alright so we can see it on the right
here I'm running this using basil as an
invocation runner just makes it a little
bit more convenient and we say hello
welcome to the image labeler what should
we take a look at all right let's try
image number one it looks like that who
knows what that is
say it out loud it sunglasses alright do
you think tensorflow agrees and yes
reasonable confidence let's let's try
another one all right what's that we
guess we're actually at a little bit of
a disadvantage of here because that
because of the ASCII art I'll show you
the real thing what's that oh yeah
that's a strawberry and tensorflow
thanks strawberry 99.98% confidence all
right it's working it's gonna make a
change to this application so I'm gonna
go into the java code here and do vim
source main job
and then myself and then there's a
greeter class in here oh look what I've
done
all right we got a greeter class in here
that says hello to you the person
running the program all right so let's
change it to hello
next ease and oops we'll go ahead and
commit that why's my xscape key not
working there we go
oh my gosh vim all right did that work
yes okay all right and then we're going
to go ahead and rerun our tests in maven
you can see that maven they're gonna
kick up my test suite and go ahead and
run through it then we'll rerun in basil
basil test all so Basil's gonna analyze
all my files compile them and run in
parallel forgot to mention what I'm
running this thing on this is two GCE
VMs 16 core machines identical machines
running maven on the left and basil on
the right
basil ran in parallel and as you can see
very rapidly found that I have an error
oh my errors in my test so we'll go
ahead actually I mean away from even to
continue to finish
Maven's running through all of its tests
taking a little longer because it's not
parallelizing still doing all the work
yeah it should be just about done here
there it is and they found the same
failure all right so the failures in my
test class let's go ahead and edit min
source test Java ba bla bla and I have a
greeter test and this funny stuff again
go ahead and edit anyway right and what
did we say we said hello next ease
that's like catching on right we're
calling ourselves that next ease
all right and we'll save that now we
have it on this one so what we do we say
just continue right all right and then
we're gonna rerun our build and test
action maven on the left basil on the
right so mavens kicking off and right I
failed somehow but as we can see basil
did it much faster its Kappa all right
see this is a coding test thank you
success and go ahead and capital that
rerun it's only gonna rerun that one
test that changed and we passed in a
very short amount of time so whoops what
was that all right so to recap with
basil we made a change
Basil's gonna look at its cache and not
bother rebuilding anything it doesn't
need to then it's gonna fan out and use
all the cores on my machine to build in
parallel now I was running this demo on
16 core machines do you use a 16 core
machine every day maybe you do I don't I
use this little laptop with two cores
and sure you can give all of your
developers 16 core machines and most of
the time they're gonna be real happy
running an IDE doesn't take a whole lot
of horsepower and if we're doing a
modest build process still pretty good
it's a little wasteful but everything is
working fine but eventually these
machines are gonna start to look
underpowered this is because build is
intrinsically a spiky workload which
means our build developer machines go
from being overpowered to underpowered
and yes even with basil because basil
can exercise all of the cores on one
machine but it can't conjure up new
cores out of thin air
or cannons remember each of these basil
actions is an independent unit of
execution which is how we can cache so
aggressively and shard across all the
cores of a machine so how about we tap
into the cloud and get a bunch more
course we can scale way beyond a single
machine and everyone in the team can
share that pool of co-worker cores so we
can bin pack those spiky workloads when
I need a build I'm gonna grab a bunch of
cores and when I'm done you can grab a
bunch of course and we can scale the
total pool to whatever we need for our
team also we can move our cache up into
the cloud so if anyone on my team has
previously built something then everyone
gets to reuse that work this is great
for getting new team members on board it
a first build for a new team member
isn't starting from scratch it's
starting from whatever the build was
that the experienced person made
yesterday or this morning today I am
excited to introduce remote build
execution for basil as a Google cloud
platform service which has just been
launched to alpha it's inspired by the
services that we use internally at
Google which are a big part of
supporting our engineering culture and
commitment to tests it's based on open
source API
developed by the basil community this is
a fully managed Google cloud service
provides scalable worker pools for
massively parallel build and test
workloads and a shared cache that every
build client whether a developer or CI
can leverage let's see it in action so
we're gonna build that same application
that we looked at earlier but this time
we're gonna go into the tensorflow
source code tensorflow is a huge project
massive c++ source code tens of
thousands of files and tests let's make
a change
if we go into the core here live there's
a string libraries and here's a file
within there and we're gonna modify this
global identifier let's see so what
should we may have our global identifier
be let's go with hello all caps didn't
mean that hello next ease I feel like I
heard someone saying that's like what
people are calling min attendees go
ahead and quit out of that alright and
then on the left side we'll go ahead and
rebuild with basil and of course it's
gonna run through all of its inputs and
figure out what work it needs to be done
and distribute that across all 16 cores
okay if there's 7,000 or so different
bits that it needs to run is actually
gonna find a few more as it runs on the
left will run that same thing test Oh
oops
all this time I'm gonna use a
configuration that includes remote build
execution do that same analysis and
start running and oh my gosh look we are
running on 600 cores so this work is
being distributed to 600 individual
workers in the cloud this is again using
that open source for protocol for remote
build distributions based on gr PC and
protobuf and it uses docker containers
to provide execute an isolation
mechanism the container is where your
work gets executed that's part of the
input to the build that's happening and
it's executed in our fully managed
service that carries the same commitment
to performance reliability and security
that you've come to expect from GCP so
now another benefit of working in the
cloud is that we can send our outputs to
a shared place so I want to show you a
cool additional feature which is this
ui4 build results this is representing
the build I'm doing right now you can
see a list here of all of the work that
basil has decided it needs to do and is
currently running through and a
successful rate and some of them that
haven't happened yet
we've got our invocation log here's a
full list of the invocation details this
is what basil is going to do and we can
get artifacts the things that Basil's
built you can go ahead and download our
intermediate libraries and things
straight out of the cloud this is
available to everyone on your team so if
I'm having a problem building I can go
to my overview page I can take this link
and copy that and send it to a colleague
and they can understand my build and the
needs that I have without having to
redownload and rebuild everything
themselves or they can go ahead and
rebuild based on knowledge of exactly
what basil build I did from this input
alright let's go ahead and refresh and
see how we're doing on our build looks
like we're getting pretty close here
check back in alright now we come down
to a bit of a pinch point you can see
that we're doing are linking that tends
to be a bottleneck we're still
distributing across dozens or hundreds
of individual nodes a lot more than I
could process on one team alright and
we've started running into the tests and
oops I have a test failure all right
using this UI that's going to pop right
to the top here's my failing target
click into my strings test and what do
we find
oh right I was supposed to write hello
next ease in my test but instead it
still says tensorflow 1.9 again this is
a great way to collaborate with
teammates send this to someone who
understands this test suite and they can
help me understand it I'm not a C++
expert but in this case it's fortunately
pretty clear what I'm supposed to do
about this pop back over still running
off a few additional final last bits
final testing and there we go we see a
summary of all the things that passed
and that
one test that failed I'm gonna go ahead
and make an edit there mmm let's see
it's under live strings numbers test all
right and this time we'll get the
capitalization correct so it was there
you know what what we copy and paste no
fat fingering here and go ahead and
paste that in save and I'm gonna rerun
my test suite this time the only change
I made was to that one test file we're
gonna recompile the test which is
running again on the remote I'm going to
relink that the singles action so it's
running in single threaded mode
effectively and rerun and what you see
is it cached all those previous results
and only reran the one test that I
needed to run again this works across
your whole team so if I'm going to make
the original error and my colleague made
the change they're gonna get inherit all
of the test results that I have got that
passed it's really great for making your
people on your team effective fast happy
to the sum up we used a shared cash to
do plate deduplicate across your entire
team the shared worker pool means I can
parallel eyes to the scale of the cloud
and cloud hosted UI improves our
effectiveness as a team communication
and joint debugging now Cal build this
was announced this week hopefully you've
been hearing about this it's a fully
managed CIC ad system on GCP and it has
out-of-the-box support for basal built
in there's a supported build step which
makes running basal workloads on cloud
build really simple just a couple lines
of code and it's got a basal optimize
your results UI for collaborative
troubleshooting so you can have basal
sorry you can have cloud build driving
your process as part of a CI system
getting that same shared cache and same
shared
cloud computing using RBE for your CI
builds enables you to fully test every
single change from one commit to the
next typically these are all small
incremental changes and so then the same
is true of pull request and even
developer builds so running using the
shared cache and the distributed pool
means that every change can be tested
because everyone's only going to re
perform the amount of work that it needs
to so the time it takes to run your test
suite is proportional to the amount of
change made not to the total size of the
codebase with remote build execution
we've been partnering with several teams
Google projects and GCP customers as
part of an early access program for RBE
and these partners have seen great
improvement in build speed and
reliability some of the workloads our
customers are running include Scala Web
Services C++ system libraries and IDE is
written in Java where we're doing full
headless testing of those interactive
environments in the nodes on GC on RBE
one of those customers is the tensorflow
team themselves they build their very
large polyglot project on ger an RBE and
they've been piloting remote build
execution with us and have achieved a 5x
improvement in their build speed that's
coupled to a 5x reduction in the amount
of machinery necessary to do these
workloads so 5x plus 5x I don't know if
that's a 10x or a 25 X but it's a lot of
X's and we're really excited about what
we're being able to achieve here they
used to have a long backlog of pull
requests testing they'd had this one
poor engineer who had to very carefully
mete out the test against this fragile
infrastructure by using these services
they've been able to run on demand every
pull request the real linear flow and
their contributors are much happier so
summing it all up
basil makes your build faster by
maximally reusing prior results and
finding out the remaining work across
all of the cores on your machine with
GCB we take it to the next level
globally reusing prior results and
fanning out the work across the cores in
the cloud if you're ready to get started
as basil there you can find installers
for Mac
Windows and Linux on the Basel website
as well as demos tutorials and great
documentation you'll also find
references to the community we've got a
mailing list at basil discuss very
active Stack Overflow communities and we
have a conference coming up in New York
this year is our second annual Basel
conference Basel con 2018 in October
find information for that on confident
Basel build to get started with Basel on
GC p shoot us an e-mail at RBE
- enquiries at google.com again that's
RBE - inquiries at google.com we have
found from our own testing inquiries is
actually kind of hard to spell so take
take a picture of that and type it
exactly
maybe those new G sweet features you saw
will help autocorrect it I'm not sure
but please reach out to us we'd love to
learn about your builds challenges are
you having and how we can help you have
faster more reliable builds we also have
a couple of the senior engineers from
the team here in the room today they and
I will all be outside we'd love to talk
to you please come that's them please
come and tell us what you're up to and
ask us questions
[Music]